接上一篇结尾的那个问题
既然技术分析不能永远来预测未来
那它到底还有什么用
先别急着下结论说
那技术分析就彻底没用了
恰恰相反
他只是换了个角色
而这个角色反而更适合现在的市场
要搞清楚这个问题
我们得先面对一个根根本的障碍
为什么人们预知行情本身就很难做到
因为很多人亏钱不是因为方法不对
而是因为一开始就把目标定错了
你把自己当成了预言家
要预测得准
你需要三样东西
大量的样本
超强的记忆力以及铁一样的执行力
但现实中呢
一个新手看过的K线可能不到1000根
样本不够
上个月那个经典形态长什么样
早就忘了
记忆力跟不上
就算看对了方向
临门一脚的时候手抖了
犹豫了
执行力又没了
有机构做过统计
一个普通交易者一年认证复盘的总次数
还不如一台普通服务器一分钟的计算量
所以大多数人所谓的预测说白了就是三个词
感觉疑问和我认为这三个词哪个都不靠谱
那既然普通人做不到预测
其实分析的正确打开方式是什么
不是预测
而是应对它的价值
不是告诉你明天会涨还是会跌
而是帮你确认当下行情是什么状态
然后基于这个状态做出一笔概率上
对自己有利的交易
这就是我们上一篇说的
从一元素变成诊断仪
诊断不是为了算命
而是为了确认现在病人是什么状态
是发烧了还是心率过快
还是一切正常
你不需要预测他明天会不会得肺炎
你只需要知道现在该不该吃药
那怎么诊断行情其实不用搞得很复杂
行情一共就两种状态
趋势和震荡趋势
就是价格在一段时间内持续往一个方向走
向一列启动了的火车震荡
就是价格在一个区间里上上下下来回跑
像一个在弹簧床上跳来跳去的人
你先得认清楚现在是哪种状态
然后才决定怎么做趋势有趋势的做法
震荡有震荡的做法
最怕的是在震荡里追涨杀跌
在趋势里高抛低吸
那基本上就是给市场送钱
那怎么判断趋势
最简单最傻瓜的方法就是均线
以EMA50和EMMA100为例
当100日线在50日线上方
且两条线都向上倾斜
这就是最简单的多头排列
你可以在render行情软件里敲出这两个参数
一眼就能看出来
当均线呈现多头排列
价格就是在趋势中
这时候你的操作逻辑只有一条
只做单边
不做逆势盈利的核心就是赌趋势会延续
别觉得赌这个字不好听
有数据统计
在均线多头排列的日线级别趋势中
第二天继续上涨的概率大约在5%
15~60不算高
但已经比抛硬币强了
关键是顺势交易的盈亏比
往往能到二比一甚至三比一
也就是说你不需要猜对
每一次
只需要在概率在你这边的时候下注
趋势就像坐自动扶梯
你不需要自己往上爬
只需要顺着方向站着
他自己会带你上去
你要做的不是去猜扶梯什么时候停
而是只要扶梯还在往上走
你就站着别动
反过来怎么判断震荡
当EMA均线缠绕在一起
价格围着均线上蹿下跳
这就是震荡
震荡行情里最忌讳的就是追涨杀跌
你一追它就回落
你一割他就反弹
正确的做法刚好相反
在下沿附近找买入机会
在上沿附近找买入机会
震荡就像在蹦床上跳
你要做的不是跟着它上蹿下跳
而是在它砸到最低点的时候
等它弹起来
这时候一个好的过滤器
能帮你省掉很多瞎猜的时间
它的作用不是告诉你这次一定涨
而是帮你筛选出概率更高的那些上沿和下沿
拿他最近一段时间的表现来说
连续给了五次信号
对了四次
错了一次
兑的时候盈亏比大概二比一
错的时候亏损控制在总资金的1%以内
算下来
扣掉手续费划点还能净赚六七个点
我不需要它每次都对
只要长期算下来
我的每一笔都有数学优势
这就是应对和预测的本质区别
预测要求你每次都对
那谁都做不到应对
只要求你长期下来赚的比亏的多
过滤器也好
指标也罢
它们的价值不是给你圣杯
而是帮你把这种概率优势稳定下来
说到这里
你心里可能已经在抬杠了
指标都是延迟的
等信号出来
价格已经走完了
这个问题问的特别好
指标确实有延迟
因为它是对过去价格的数学计算
但我反问你一句
人脑是不是也是延迟的
你知道人的平均反应时间是多少吗
看到一根K线变化到手指
点击鼠标最快也要200ms
散户的优势从来不在快
快是机构的赛道
毫秒级决胜几千台服务器堆在那里
连光线的长度都要精确到米
你跟他比快
就像骑自行车跟高铁赛跑
不是不能跑
是完全没有意义
散户的优势在于
等你不需要吃到整条鱼
你只需要吃到鱼身上最确定的那一段
为此你愿意放弃鱼头和鱼尾
就像钓鱼
你不需要比鱼游得快
你只需要在正确的位置
正确的时间把钩放下去
然后等那些拼命想比别人快一步的人
往往是最先被吃掉的人
有句话说的特别好
快人一步盆满钵满
快人两步倾家荡产
那些拼了命都想抢跑的人
坟头草都3米高了
所以当你下次打开图表的时候
不要再逼自己去猜接下来会涨还是跌
你只需要问自己两个问题
现在是什么状态
在这个状态下
概率站哪一边
如果趋势向上
你只找做多的机会
如果趋势向下
你只找做空的机会
如果是震荡
你只找边界返乡的机会
这就叫应对
不叫预测